good afternoon everybody today we're
going to do a session on b2b product we
have a panel
Jason Lemkin is going to moderate thank
you very much
we have Solomon from docker Tracy from
plan grid and Harry from lob thank you
all very much for coming so this is a
great session everyone's seen all the
prior sessions online right raise your
hand if you haven't
all right good 100% they're great so I
watched Aaron Levie and we had deska
Moskovitz in Stewart Butterfield and
others and what I thought would be
particularly fun since we have three
amazing founders here of b2b companies
is to particularly hone in on the
intersection of building great products
and revenue because we all want to be
product visionaries I I certainly did
myself but if you can't sell it and it
would be to be product ultimately what's
what's the point of all of it so I want
to dig into a couple stories both in the
early days and a little bit later to
help folks like you probably are just
have Inklings of how to potentially
monetize your dreams because the stories
are always different than we think so
let me give 10 seconds on each of the
panelist and let me have them dig in a
little bit more on their companies but
Solomon from docker I don't know who
here knows about docker but I'm guessing
most of the 300,000 folks online that'll
that'll read it but docker
he'll give you some more context founded
in 2010 but not as docker as what was a
call back then the cloud dot cloud which
we'll get to a story raised almost 200
million and docker is sort of a
foundational piece of infrastructure
that everyone builds software on today
so we'll get into that but it is seven
years into this journey right into a
likely a 70 year journey or 14 year
journey um Tracy probably in plan gets
probably in the middle of this of this
Rockstar group planned grid was found a
little bit later 2011 got it raised 60
million right so money isn't everything
but it does help and plan greed you'll
learn is super cool automates
construction management and kind of has
shaken up a shockingly large industry
shockingly large parts of software and
you learn a little bit more about those
stories and I want to learn more and
then there
three runs lob and which turns mail into
an api which i think is pretty
interesting raised ten million so he's
got another 190 million to catch up on
50 million but off to a very strong
start on it in 2013 so you're what's a
tell yeah all right so you've in your
four years in right so it's just when
it's getting both good and hard right at
the same time I would imagine right so I
want to begin but those the intros but
give me a little bit more intro on the
company like number of employees and
what's the what's that what's the latest
challenge about today or any other quick
quick tidbits on the company sure so
currently it's 350 employees at docker
we actually started in 2008 2008 yeah
we're bootstraps in France and then it
wasn't working so we moved here got into
YC and that really really really helped
so anyway got in 9 years 9 years sort of
rebound the company we reach now here
you know campus earlier it depends who
you ask but yeah it counts the same
company same problem we're trying to
solve so 350 employees lots of growth
lots of excitement the biggest challenge
for us and the biggest challenge last
year was proving that we could build a
business viable hydros business on top
of this excitement for stuff that is in
large part free and open source right
and that was last year we proved that
model and this year with the challenge
to scale it and the scale it faster than
our competitors who now figured out that
the model is proven so it was a big
competitive battle and a really
lucrative space so that's a challenge
this year good hi everyone my name is
Tracy young I'm one of the co-founders
and CEO plan grid plan grid builds as he
said beautiful simple effective software
for the construction industry we emerged
from Y Combinator's winter 2012 batch
and since then we've grown from five
cofounders to three hundred and ten
people which is not something to brag
about and means our payroll is very high
um but we've helped build over 500,000
construction projects from the smallest
kitchen remodel
to the largest projects in the world and
we are available on all the platforms
Apple actually named us one of the top
10 enterprise apps of 2016 which is
pretty awesome
now we're also the largest digital
blueprint repository in the world we
have over 50 million sheets of
blueprints in our cloud and growing
thanks
so I'm sitting here looking up 40
employees hope and I wish had 150 but a
little bit about lob one of the founders
my name is harry zhang started company
in 2013 and what we do is build tools to
make it easy for developers to control
the offline world so we actually deal
with a physical component an industry
that many of you think may be dying but
in fact is very much the opposite doing
with letters postcards and other types
of mail I'm really building a layer of
technology on top of that to make it
easy for companies to do that so
hopefully many of you have received a
piece of mail from WAP especially in
this area and the bay area and we
service companies you know we're trying
to make this switch into selling to you
know mid market and other startups and
to selling into the 4 to 500 so a lot of
our challenges today is really how do we
move into enterprise and take what used
to be you know a one single tool and
translate it into a larger full solution
for larger companies good so hang on to
the microphone because there's just one
other question I want to the whole panel
but I like I really like to talk about
the concept of a minimum sellable
product not a viable product like what
it actually takes to make real money so
Harry tell me what what happened with
lob do not count other companies from
your batch or customers you got a packer
news what how did you get that first
those first unaffiliated customers and
what made the product sellable yeah yeah
I think one of the common things that's
easy to get in the habit of thinking
that customers are in come to you
because you have a great product has a
great solution we that works maybe in
the beginning for smaller companies but
as you go after your first real customer
our first real customer was was Oscar
insurance over in New York so the thing
the way we got to them was cold email
and we sent thousands and thousands of
emails I personally wrote like every
single one
and got a response from the CEO and I
think one of the the key things is to
really have an understanding of why our
company is going to talk to you what is
the problem that you're solving for them
as opposed to like here's what my
product does and these are the features
that I have right you want to be very
pinpoint about what that message is
people are actually surprisingly open to
respond your email as long as it's
relevant
so for us we happen to hit on the
problem for Oscar which is they had a
male vendor and they knew there's this
regulation called HIPAA which
essentially how you govern and control
private health information and what we
realize was that this was our
opportunity and they were looking at new
vendors they did not trust their
existing vendor had HIPAA and was secure
and we could point to a small customer
we had already done it for in the past
and that's how I got into the
conversation just about you know two
three months to get the deal done but
really what you need is to identify a
core problem that larger companies
haven't quite figured out and even if
your solution isn't the best you know
that's out there you need to be to a
point where the customers willing to buy
so we start off of one use case very
very simple explanation of benefits
today we said you know probably 50
different types of mail checks postcards
practically everything but the key is to
pick one small use case that you they
need have a real problem around and that
you're going to go solve so that's what
we did Oscar and you know it's it's
funny to the state are still one of our
larger customers and it all just came
from like a three sentence email to
their CEO do you remember what the
headline of the email was I'm is like we
can help you if you're male we can help
you with your mail that work it did work
it's we've now learned a lot that that's
probably what I do today but at the time
we knew that you know healthcare sent a
lot of mail and we also we also did that
you've got mail which got a pretty good
chuckle from folks in a day but really
the the core of the content was in the
first two lines which is like we know
companies have problems sending secure
audible mail yeah we built a technology
solution around doing this yet fifteen
minutes to talk about it alright that's
pretty much what the the core content
was but the key is to get straight to
the point what are you going to solve
what's the problem and you know asking
for a little bit more time I never
talked to CEO but you pond
me down to change but got the right guys
eventually so Tracy if I I'm not an
expert but I you're probably competing
with bigger traditional older incumbents
in some ways the mob was right do I have
that wrong
what got you sellable what got you
really off the ground every beautiful
software's great but we all want to
build that right what made it what made
it sellable sure first ten users I'm
trained as a construction engineer so
the first ten users were definitely
people we had worked with in the field
and it's easy to get our friends to try
out our software it's incredibly
difficult to get our friends to start
paying for it so so they're building
something that they wanted and that they
needed that added undeniable value to
their day to day was a moment they
started paying us was the feedback from
your non paying friends useful was it
was it was it unhelpful was it dis
helpful
so our first beta group which included
you know mostly people wouldn't work
within the field was about 30 people 29
of them started paying us as soon as the
beta was over they did pay got it okay
so were they were they bigger critics
and outside customers nuns it's hard to
it's hard to figure out how to take
advantage of friends as yeah you're
really testing my memory so I'm no it
was it was at that point in 2011/2012 is
about I want this to do more for us can
you build the XYZ got it
and what was obviously the product was
feature poor at the time right what was
what was the one piece that was 10x
better so blueprints are at the core
plan grid replaces physical blueprint
you know fold-out maps we don't have
them anymore actually with this group
you guys probably have never purchased a
fold-out map before but we use ways we
use Apple maps with these Google Maps
and with blueprints it's the same
analogy these massive incredibly dense
pieces of paper with information and
they just don't render quickly on PDF
viewers so um it was just so what was
the one line what was the pitch to make
your beautiful product sellable was it
red hot I was hoping you'd ask me what
the tagline was what was the fact our
tagline and this is from my co-founder
Kenny our tagline was plan grid
eliminates the because up that
marketing has now changed it so we're
the were the productivity software for
construction got it okay well we'll dig
in more on that
so boy which part where do we want to
answer this question so we started we
start hosting applications right for
others
yeah the early history what didn't tell
us what didn't work or at least didn't
scale in that what did work sure in
salable product so the background here
is so nine years and we started out as a
company called dot cloud and now we're a
different company called docker but
there is a common thread right it's the
same companies the same team with the
same mission but we changed how we do it
in the first phases at clouds we well
let me start with what the common thread
is the common thread is we help
developers be more productive we give
them tools to create applications and
then we help the businesses behind those
developers solve their business problems
with the creation of software and we're
serving on these trends of more people
creating software to do more things so
the first phase we did that by hosting
the applications so we said just write
the code upload it to us we'll take care
of everything we'll run it for you we'll
manage it for you all of it and and then
now it's docker we don't do the hosting
we provide the tools you use the tools
yourself and then you host the
application and eventually as a business
you need help with various aspects of
distributing your software at large
scale yo in the first phase we're very
small we didn't have any sort of hype
behind us we were just trying to
convince developers to use our stuff and
and we used honestly we used our own
community were programmers we write
software and we know a lot of other
programmers and we just annoyed the hell
out of all of them to use our stuff we
gave it to them for free and then kind
of through through the individual
programmers eventually made our way to
the business behind the programmer so
the difference I think is that for us
it's a two step process where are our
users and our biggest advocates are not
the people paying for the for the
products so so that means we have to
give a lot of stuff away for free before
we even
get the first conversation with the
actual buyer yeah so how did you so
those first early years it's not even
the same product you have today remotely
right how did you survive raise 50
million in your seed round or no how did
you pull this off right no so I think
the hard part right well so when you're
a very small team you know you you have
kind of a limited window of time where
you can survive and not a lot yeah
harden usually collect last much more
than 24 months isn't it that's right but
yeah yeah so we joined Y Combinator in
2010 and you know raised our first small
round of funding at the end of 2010 so
within six months and we got got went at
it gradually I mean it's nothing nothing
particularly unique there but you got
into YC
about twenty four months after founding
so that was yeah so the first part was
really tough it was bootstraps we did
consulting we did whatever getting with
the Hat whatever it was a hack whatever
we had to do to pay the bills it was
really tough my advice would be
consulting and product building are
they're very useful but you got to get
out of it really quickly because it's
just the consulting takes all of your
time you will never get off the ground
as a product company it there's too much
distraction consulting so eventually we
just took a leap of faith yeah
and landed in our feet in Y Combinator
so got it and then one last question and
then I want to move on to the next topic
but so what is now docker has gone
through two-and-a-half evolutions with
business model right and you've made
open source work for you right what's
that what's the secret there what's the
learning because it's a lot we think
it's hard to monetize open source yeah
so honestly I don't know how useful my
insights are here because really the
trick is to get really lucky and you
know that the situation we're in now is
that the the open source technology that
we developed docker is extremely popular
it you know we were in the right place
at the right time there's this whole
trend around containers which we kind of
helps start and now just the demand for
it is honestly hard to describe so
you you start having a completely
different set of problems once you're in
that situation so honestly the problems
we had before that moment in 2013 when
we launched the open source docker and
after our worlds apart yeah now honestly
it's more how do we deliver on the
incredible demand fast enough before
competitors do it instead so there is no
outbound in my case the question is too
much inbound which seems like a nice
thing but it's actually you know it's
it's noise and it's also you drop a lot
of it on the floor yeah and and your
competitors pick it up yeah
so Tracy let's come back to I want to
come back to your fun story you hit up
30 of your friends from construction 29
became customers as you scale how what
do you do with customer feedback how
important is this how much do you listen
to how much of it is noise how much do
you let it guide your roadmap what have
you learned I don't know how you build
product without listening to your
customers feedback we certainly take
incredibly seriously we've we've logged
and categorized every single piece of
feedback that our clients have given us
since 2011 it's incredibly easy we've
made that process you just come on
client or calm and you're like I want to
give you feedback and then our support
team will take it they'll ship it over
to the product team we'll look at it
every quarter and it does help us
prioritize the the big task care is
making sure that we're prioritizing the
right stuff because sometimes our users
will ask us you know can finder and make
up my breakfast and dinner and so you
know when when there's large job
contractors and smaller subcontractors
and building owners asking us for the
same button and telling us that if you
just have this thing it's going to save
me so much time and there's enough
domain experience on the team like when
so many customers are asking for the
same thing it's probably the right thing
to build
although trucking is obviously important
but we typically look at it as like how
hard is this to build how much resources
do we have to put into this versus how
much value and impact is it going to
give our users and if it's like low
level of effort and high impact we're
going to prioritize that absolutely
and that's really helped us guide our
product roadmap and if you have you had
any of your bigger customers drag your
roadmap in a different way than your
smaller customers yes the the larger
customers you know they they want to be
treated like princess princess and
princesses that they're you know running
our entire business but they're
incredibly supportive of us it's it's
nice that not one any single one
customer has that big of a percentage of
our revenue and so we you know they just
want to make sure that we're listening
to them and that we're showing them what
the feature of plan grid looks like that
we're constantly improving it because
they're not only buying kinder today but
they're applying buying plan good six
months from now it's a commitment right
it's a relation is a long-term
commitment right and so and how many
customers total do you have a plan good
tens of tens of thousands tens of
thousands but the revenue distribution
it's probably several orders of
magnitude at your biggest customers
right when even if it's a couple percent
of revenue or maybe in the early days
when they ask you to build something
that's kind of on your roadmap that's
way out there because this is an issue
we all face do you build it you know the
the b2c guys always say no right but
when you're big customer wants you to
build a 20-19 feature do you build it
again if there's like ton of the big
customers asking us for the same thing
it's easy to prioritize that but we have
never built a feature out for just one
customer that doesn't make sense we're
building software for the construction
industry not XYZ construction got it
yeah Harry love is there difference
between the different size customers
definitely big the product between our
large or small customers we spent a lot
of time focusing on like the larger
customers right I think one thing you
mentioned earlier right do our larger
customers impact our roam at they
certainly do right that said I think
it's also about being transparent in the
conversation from the first deal like
what are you building they're not just
selling one particular feature one
particular it's a road map right it's
like you're investing a lot you're going
to be building infrastructure on it like
we need to talk to that real map and one
larger customers are purchasing they're
looking at what are we building you know
six months from now
kind understand what that is and for us
it's about finding the balance between
like the type of customers
we want and listening to those customers
a little bit more not more strategic so
for us we're solving something that's
very ubiquitous right mail comes in many
shapes format sizes and there's
literally endless amounts of
combinations that we could do and if we
entertained every single requests we did
end up going a million directions all
the time so for us we focus very
strategically on operational mail so
mail that customers are compliant and
required to send as opposed to marketing
mail right that's not to say we don't do
a lot of marketing mail we still do but
when we think about row map
conversations and it comes to a
trade-off between a or B we're always
going look at the customer who won we
have a relationship with right - is the
direction that we want the company and
move to begin with and that's how we
prioritize that and sometimes that means
saying no to customers and oftentimes we
found they're okay if that's so long as
you're transparent about what you're
trying to do yeah so someone looks like
you said in the beginning you guys were
five five co-founders for two years
right
I think no roughly I have that wrong no
I think I heard type co-founders oh it's
a Tracy cloud yeah we'll get into equity
splits later okay and then at 51 did I
learn how that but okay but anyhow
related question so but I want it I want
to ask most the panel this as you scale
let's talk about because this is always
great learning I'm miss hire right so as
you get out of your core team is there a
core functional area or VP or someone
that you thought you needed or got wrong
in the early days anything you can learn
from what's the biggest hire in the
station made I don't know about the
biggest but we made a lot as well we
made a lot
I think everyone I don't know anyone who
hasn't everyone might yeah but we can
learn from this then that yeah we can
exhibit this mistake a little little
fewer times yeah I think I mean the
biggest challenge is once you grow into
full fledged company then you grow
outside of your zone of concert if
you're of comfort if you're a technical
if you're on the technical and product
side then you have to hire not you know
business people on the business side you
have to hire more technical and product
leadership and you know it's things that
at some point you don't know and you
don't know what you don't know and I
remember as an engineer hiring
non-engineers it was very difficult for
me because
I knew I needed help but I didn't have
the know-how to distinguish the
different kinds of non engineers that I
needed it seems really silly to say that
but to me you know marketing was just
you know marketing in sales it was like
the the not coding thing and also I
moved to the u.s. from France yeah and
Americans are extremely good at selling
themselves you know I hear that a lot
from European founders I hear that as I
can so you're right here and you meet 10
people are like wow these are all rock
stars orbit their land grid and bomb
it's in yeah hire em right then and
there and and you do and then you
realize okay there's more to this and
the biggest problem is you're when you
hire the wrong person yeah you're you're
the state of mind is oh it's a bad
person you know they're bad and and my
company's good and now I heard the bad
person but really what's happening is it
everyone's wasting their time it's it's
it's it's not the right combination of
people and you're going to find out six
months later and it's going to be a
terrible nuisance so I don't really know
if I've learned anything how to avoid it
but every time we made a mistake we've
tried to really invest a time to go back
and find out why what we did wrong so
that we don't make the same mistake
twice
honestly yeah and I guess again decide
it's the hire it's not about that your
fault isn't it yeah yeah exactly that's
exactly right and and my feeling is it's
the hardest at the beginning but if you
find once you have a core group of
people like five key people and areas
that you don't really understand and
master but you build a relationship of
trust with those people yeah then it
gets easier because you trust them to
hire more people the really bad
situation is if you don't sort out that
stuff early on like you make a hire you
feel like it might be a bad hire but you
don't deal with it right away
you allow it to fester and then before
you know it you're growing and that
person has hired 20 more people and now
you're in big trouble because now you
got to deal with the mismatch
potentially with 20 people so I would my
only advice would be you're going to
make mistakes just deal with them early
and listen to your gut you know if your
gut says
maybe this is the wrong thing you know
trust yourself even if it's not your
field of expertise I mean probably
repeating a common sense here but I will
really all make the same mistake Tracy I
want to hear your story too but let me
flip it around you have five co-founders
right so you've got you probably had a
lot of the you felt like you had at
least two or two of the bases covered in
the early days at least in theory right
who were who what was a one of these
early hires you made that was extremely
impactful that moved the needle that
helped increase the business our
employee number one boy number one who
is because there's just core lorenz you
know we're early on there's nothing and
you have to build something from nothing
the more people that we can get onto the
team to help realize our mission as a
company is incredibly important and I
would say the same about employee number
two and point number three employee
number three hundred yeah was there a
particular functional area or someone
that changed things for you we they're
all great and we brought them on because
we needed help right so it's hard to
just pinpoint one person for sure
well let me ask a different question you
have five founders when Wendy bring on
VPS or directors or others to take over
the functional areas from them what did
you learn from that experience yeah the
point when we realize that we you know
as being a founder especially doing it
for the first time so much of our jobs
is just learning on the spot and trying
to get it to work get it get the job
done as we've recruited more and more
people that seemed there comes a point
where it's like wow we have to become
really good at managing people and it
was all new for the founders I think we
got pretty good at it
especially as like just a frontline
engineering manager but there comes to a
point where we're at like 50 people 150
people and it's like Dunbar's numbers
like complete chaos
suddenly communication gets so much
harder and I think that's when we
started layering in executives who had
done it before because now we have
experience of people who aren't who
aren't like the founders aren't learning
on the job they've done it before
they've done it three times before very
successfully and it's just like is much
easier to run the business that way yeah
that's a good insight of when we all we
all want to hire the folks who've done
it before
really right not all of us but we get
attracted to the to the to the to the
box on the resume but maybe that Dunbar
number is the right time to think about
it right when did you benefit from folks
that maybe weren't as fluent in the
product but we're fluent in the process
the processes yeah if I could do it over
I'd probably bring them on earlier but
at that point it's just like you're
trying to recruit someone who's very
very good at their jobs who are getting
paid tons of money at wherever they're
at and it's hard to recruit them to your
you know little ship startup all right
but you know you sell you sell your
butts off actually you never stopped
selling your butts off about your
mission your vision as a company and so
being able to deliver that message of
what you're trying to do and also
showing the traction showing the growth
that's when you see that graph everyone
wants to be a part of it they doing yeah
it was there a moment Recruiting's
always hard but was there a moment when
it got easier practice practicing get
caesar so I'd say by land perspective
the plan could get to the point and did
you know Sukhoi or others or press or
you or did it get it's always I want to
I want to ask a related question but it
did get in some way easier when you
became a more interesting startup to a
broader community yeah so you know we're
a YC company we're also in the Sequoia
portfolio we flash that to our advantage
yeah
so good so Harry what any any learnings
on hiring mistakes or great hire you
made what move the needle for you yeah
so I can actually talk to one you
mentioned earlier just like realizing
that you need to hire good managers it's
a big moment for us and passed like a
couple of years and that was actually
one of the early mistakes we made which
is like one of our best ICS thought he
wanted to be a manager and we really
wanted him to manage team two he hadn't
actually had experience doing that
before and when we put him in that role
he struggled and that had some you know
put us through like a tough six months
right and I think we learned the lesson
early on it's like you want people who
have already done it once before because
even though you may trust somebody and
they're awesome of what they do there's
it's hard to discount the value of
experience right and that's something
like just having seen it before the type
of
palms you can see that's made a big
difference so for us like I'd say like
you know first most huge hires like we
had somebody in our head meant to enroll
ed and pan out and our second head of
engineering was just incredible right
he literally made problems disappear
like things that we would sit there and
worry about at dinner my co-founder
talking about like this and this people
this year then next thing we knew like
literally three weeks after he started
like we just never talked about it heard
about it again everyone seemed to be
happy and working harder and staying
longer and what we didn't really feel
like we're doing anything different you
know we just had somebody different on a
roll and you know finally did you know
30 days or that how quickly did you know
is impact probably with an hour so we
had the Vantage already having someone
the rules so sort of knew what good look
like and what great was and obviously
we're always looking at that but you
know in the first 30 days I think you
can immediately tell the difference
they're having at the team even within
the first you know first two weeks a lot
of learning and you can just tell from
the quality of questions that they're
asking right what are they thinking
about how far they playing ahead and
then really like we started to see a lot
of changes happen the second week in
terms of like taking everything they
learned throughout the interview process
getting to know the company and also
adopting it to their own style right and
I think first and foremost like not just
hiring for experience but hiring for a
culture foot is really really important
you know we had have had great hires in
the past awesome I sees that we let
Fester a little too long because of
cultural things and you know having the
rewind that back and you know few years
later was definitely challenging so I
think in a culture fit now if we spend a
ton of time through our interview
process we've changer we've updated our
values worked into the interview process
each person is responsible for asking
one particular and component of that and
that's like one of the first things we
evaluate regardless and not whether the
person can do the job it's like easy yet
is this someone we'd work with and it's
someone who's going to fit well and
really bring their own individual skill
set to the company yeah good point
Tracy let me let me go back to a point
you made about the journey that your
customers are sign up for six and twelve
months and maybe they're even signed up
for 60 months and 100 months especially
in the early days or you know products
are super feature poor right I mean you
had 29 folks sign up immediately but
it's still teach how do you how do you
convince them to go on that journey
and you have incumbents that are
feature-rich what's what have you
learned there's nothing like adoption in
the field so there's certainly lots of
incumbents some that you know very well
there's also a lot of startups here and
that are just you know if you have any
success at all your software will be
copied you guys are dealing with that
right now and so just making sure that
we are developing products that are
actually being used in the field has
been key to plan grid success that
regardless of what VP of operations or
CIOs want to deploy the software that's
being used on construction site yes like
for real is is our software because
super ensure we were building software
for the superintendent's and Foreman's
and carpenters and electricians in a way
that is actually powerful to them that
actually helps them do their jobs better
so you're a lot of your history so this
is learning for me but a lot of history
is coming in from the field even if the
CEOs office or wherever it is they build
software for them too so you know we've
got admin panels we have episode coming
out for them we've got you know
beautiful graphs and stuff because they
are they are a decision maker and that's
important to us but I think early days I
mean first four years of planned grid
yes we're definitely not prioritizing
products for for the people in the
office and would you with what and how
and let's just talk about that for me
because that's always interesting right
and so you get into the field they love
your product they can adopt it
immediately instead of taking six months
and how do you how did you deal with
that conflict if this if a different
vendor had already been selected by
procurement or any learnings on how this
yeah without our industry super
interesting because we we essentially
sell the construction projects there's
certainly construction companies that
manage like several projects of the time
but the beauty of our industry and it's
also it looks like both the best and
worst thing is when we're in a
construction project there's actually 50
different customers for us to sell to
there are the carpenters there's
electricians with the concrete folks the
pool installers the paint person and so
there's this natural virality that
happens within construction projects a
foreman starts using plan grant and it's
a cultural thing too
the construction person you just want to
show off your shiny new tool and plan
words so cool that you sort of want to
be the first one to show everyone else
on the project and so we were always
laser focused at building something that
was easy to adopt easy to use and that
would sort of spark that Network effect
within construction projects so here's
corporate standardizing on a software
then you've got the field which the the
person really paying for it is a
building owner yeah and so we've just
been laser focused at getting our
software adopted at the ground level
which is very different than any other
software in the space and you and you
spend a lot of time on those other users
that actually don't write it that don't
pay for a pine grid all the other folks
on the project how do you make them
happy - yeah we made sure to build
something that was flexible enough that
would that could be used by anyone in
the architectural engineering and
construction industry the prioritizing
product is a key factor here yeah we
didn't want to build something that was
just for one profile we wanted it to be
flexible flexible enough that it could
be used by everyone in the industry yeah
so since a'lamin let's talk a variant of
this sort of competition a long journey
for you I I am I feel like Dockers a
product and a vendor that people are
rooting for I think there are a lot of
the docker fans I would say how do you
how do you how do you invest in that how
do you can you return that social
contract in the product side especially
as competition increases right as you
prove yourself everyone wants to do
something in the broad container market
competitions everywhere how do you how
do you keep that like hundred MPs that
docker probably has yeah
so there's your MPs we measure well we
measure in PAP anis do the problem for
us is who do we ask because there's a
lot of different audiences actually it's
really interesting comparison I think
the same thing is happening a lot of
industries there's a sort of a bottom-up
go to market right where first you get
the petitioners on boards and then you
get their bosses on board maybe later
maybe you know maybe they learn about
your product only once
dozens or hundreds of people in the
organization are using it even today a
dagger
so it's this yeah so we use that a rogue
app and some we use that too heavily yes
yeah and and so today as a business we
target enterprises very large businesses
that is our focus we sell also to small
businesses we're kind of in a similar
situation you get the tens of thousands
and then the majority of the revenue
comes from a few hundred but all of them
are in this relationship with us as a
vendor because someone on their team at
some point said new app awesome docker I
went to meet up sounds great or I saw
saw discussion online about it so we oh
everything to that to that community and
there's a lot of positive vibes in that
community honestly is pretty insane if
you've ever been to a doctor meetup or
we had a doc work on I was like five
thousand people right it's it's
ridiculous honey in the early days how
do you facilitate that what are the
learning how do you get that fly will go
you know it's honestly we we started
something very small and the day ten
people should we showed it to a few
people one by one and then ten of them
came back to our office saying hey we
want to know more and it was just the
most fun three hours of my life
basically were just talking about all
the cool stuff we could build a docker
and then they came back the week after
that and it was 40 people and it was a
hundred so pretty pretty cool that there
was the first week of the existence of
docker yeah and so right away we saw
okay there's something special going on
here and there's a community forming and
they're basically saying hey you the
company you started this your you're the
janitor now like make sure you know that
organize things for us because this is
our thing now and so we just took that
job really seriously of enabling that
community to do whatever it decides to
do so we've been following that
community ever since and just removing
obstacles for that community to grow do
more things together and so we have a
whole team that's focused on that
enabling the community we have all these
cool programs we have I think a hundred
twenty meetups in the world a hundred
thousand people have honored finally
made ups here all right no so is 120
locations in the world each with you
know an average of meet up every two
months or so
and then 100,000 people I think overall
have showed up at least once to one of
these meetups there is a there's a
captain's program which is sort of a
like elite you know power user where you
know that the the most savvy and
articulate users of docker we kind of
promote them and and pay them for them
to go and speak at events and they just
become these stars in the community so
we just it's a huge investment for us
but it's all about all of it is about
giving back God how many of these
captains are there out of here I think
now there's uh maybe twenty thirty small
number it sounds like a lot for some of
us it's ironic a sense right I love
captain but you said you had four
hundred employees I mean they're not
employees but it's a significant amount
of your extended family
yes correct yeah and so it's anyway that
when you see a community when you see
anyone super excited about what you're
doing just drop everything you're doing
and make sure you put themselves as your
service at their service in our case
it's developer is using an open-source
tool you know but it it looks like
there's something similar going on I'm
sure there's I'm going to say wrong but
whatever the job is of someone actually
working on a construction site some of
them I'm sure are just huge fans of the
tool they go everywhere and they just
they tale tell all their buddies about
it and and I think that's how consumer
products used to grow I think now it's
increasingly seeing the best b2b
products also grow that way let's make
that our last questions I want to save a
few minutes for questions so we have it
but related to that but I think I
already know the answer for docker so
let's just do plan great in law but
Tracy today what percent of your new
customers come from word of mouth or
brand or what what this all this great
goodwill that you've built across the
industry yeah I out today we definitely
ship Facebook ads and stuff but most of
our new customers comes from comes from
just word of mouth organic growth which
is awesome but then it's also
uncontrollable right it's just some kind
of comes naturally to us and we don't
know what sparks it but we know that if
we make our clients happy and we build
great product for them the thought does
continue to happen
yeah after year
is that happening at Lafayette you get
most of your customers from the base
yeah our base customers are the folks
are referring a good portion I'm not
having to find all the emails yourself
today anymore no I mean what we've
actually found you know some of us
almost saying one of the things is
interesting we have these folks have
been at three different companies in
like a four year span and have used a
lot that three companies that's what
you're working the area see my bringing
you line right and it's great because
you know every time I get an email from
it's like at different companies like
hey I want to bring you here I look
great I love a chat with you
yeah and you want those those folks who
are going to be your evangelists who
love your product everywhere they go
they're going to find a way to use you
because they like it right and that's
that's really important and that played
a big part for some of our other
customers going to different companies
bringing us there and then you also get
the referrals like you know especially
you what you want to do is you want to
create word-of-mouth and we found this
to be very successful at conferences
right where we already have a good
foundational layer of companies so for
us like fin tack in the lending space is
a big one all right so we're going out
we're out lend it and our customers will
bring their friends over for booth oh
yeah these guys are great right and
there's nothing like a positive referral
from someone who's existing customer to
somebody else that's doing something
very similar and that is part of the
reason why we go every single year and
we sit there smile we host customer
appreciation of that and eventually we
love to get to a point where we could do
like a a lob con you know get flex folks
together you may you may be ready
already actually I think I think right
may be ready all right we keep going on
this but let's take some questions
anyone got any great questions for the
balance thing like what was your past it
would would like one past expense that
you think helped you the most while
starting your own company Jason can you
repeat the question
I can the question was what was one oh
yeah I like redundancy I worry
I like five nines of uptime what was one
experience prior to starting your
company that actually helped you get it
off the ground so two of the five
cofounders of plan guard had built
buildings before and the other three
were building software just our ability
to like rally resources and people and
build something together
to work together really helped us work
in a start-up together it just feels
like the mediums changed for me instead
of concrete and brick it's it's people
people and code and more people do you
think you can penetrate the industry
with no domain expertise I mean I'm sure
it's been done but what you're learning
on domain expertise I think it's
possible you just have to become an
expert fast so somehow you could
compensate for it are you come on that
one a little bit you know I didn't have
any domain expertise in mail I don't
think a ton of people had domain
expertise in mail I am an expert now
though and certainly that's something
I've learned but for me past experience
right I spent when I came out of college
I went on with the Microsoft and this is
like the last place in the world you'd
expect to send mail and have it be
effective one of the projects I worked
on there we for multiple different
privacy reasons like we're not allowed
to email we couldn't do that a channel
for another couple reasons and like my
only option was either calling everybody
which didn't seem very you know feasible
at the time or sending people all these
nice little kits and turns out like the
best-performing thing was male and I
ended up spending three months and like
hundreds of thousand dollars huge
budgets like working on this and
realizing that this is something like
people actually do and companies like
Microsoft you every day and it works but
it's really hard and it's ancient like
we have people suggesting us like
automation paying tens of thousand
dollars for implementation to get like
an FTP folder that we like drop an excel
file to and it seems sort of ridiculous
but as part of the inspiration for how
we started working on lob go ahead
whether it's all about a companies who
help or a competing service or products
that can understand operations expertise
can be like a box like that
yeah or let's listen how do you deal
with big companies that can do it all
right how do you deal with that
situation yes I think there's probably
there's a generic answer that's true for
every business and then there is for
every startup and then there's maybe
some domain specific answers I think the
the personally I think something that's
true for all startups is that you have
focus and you have speed and I had never
were
at a large company before so I did not
appreciate exactly the advantage we have
as a smaller company but now that we're
growing a little bit I can already tell
what happens when you grow and so the
goal really is to take advantage of our
small size while we're small faster than
we accumulate problems as we grow when
when you're when you're big and you have
a successful business everyone working
there you the majority of people working
there first of all we're not there at
the time when the business became
successful so they all it's long
forgotten how they became successful in
the first place they're administrating
an existing cash cow and so there's a
completely different kind of people
generally speaking right except maybe at
the very top you had a few VPS there you
know the original guy who did it and
then he's running something but usually
these are people who at a large your
average large company they're they're
not united as one group to make to make
that that company succeed against
outside threats like you they are
focused usually on their career are they
going to get promoted are they going to
get more people under them you know it's
inside facing rather than outside facing
and most large companies are like that
and that's that's an advantage because
they're not looking for threats the
other advantage is focus large companies
tend to be doing a lot of things and
when you're competing with a company it
has 10,000 people and you have 10 it
might seem really daunting but the
particular parts of that company that is
actually competing with you for all you
know might also be 10 people and they
might be underfunded they might be on
the wrong side of the big boss who just
doesn't care about the product and over
time as you start competing you'll find
out which ones are serious threats and
which ones are basically to be ignored
it's hard to tell from the outside hard
to tell that as as you start getting a
becoming an expert and you talk to
customers I mean it's pretty it's pretty
easy customers are going to say well I'm
thinking about you and these other two
three things and some names are going to
come up a lot and some of them will be
other startups some of them will be
other big companies and then you narrow
down your focus and you
right okay what makes that big company
smarter than the others but it's you can
break down the problem basically go
ahead fact is that these customers
televisions first value products that's
the that's the magic question what do
you think the biggest actors are that
create the sort of math they get other
customers to refer you out what can you
point to specifically I mean a short
answer is good product something
something that that saves them time
ascendancy that's all that's all we care
about we've got this one precious thing
that we don't get more of and because
plan grid absolutely saves our users
time it's why they've told everyone else
but let me just in Kerala me a very net
collection so you have the great story
of the customer that left that the 3 X 3
X that's a great story but in b2b it's
hard for that to happen in three weeks
right how many how long did that take to
get that those three customers out of
that first great experience yeah I think
the first thing I realized was customers
aren't going to just all of a sudden
start referring them to you they want to
build a relationship and trust you and
the only reason why that happened is
because the first year it went from this
this particular individual like start
off as a very very small like a couple
thousand dollar a month customer and
grew to be like a fifty sixty thousand
dollar month customer very very large in
a short period of time and we did a lot
like in a lot of things we are very
transparent that like hey we we can't
get this done in this timeframe here's
what we can do you know I had a cell
phone number we frequently tax when
things go wrong and for us I think the
biggest reason why he actually wouldn't
refer to us is because of how we handle
things when things didn't go the way we
planned right everybody wants projects
to go perfectly launched on time like
and the reality is it doesn't always
happen that way and sometimes there's
factor side your control but I think the
way that we handle ourselves when things
didn't go planned was a huge vote in
confidence that like this is a company
that we can trust because like we're
watching people scramble and I remember
there's one instance around Christmas
like some deliveries didn't happen for
key customers we went out and like drove
out and just like delivered it comes out
Leo the guys like down the street it's
not big deal we'll just go get it done
and he was hugely appreciative and it
was a small thing right and it was a
very
small campaign that he was doing but a
stories like that that he clings on to
when he goes to a new you know a new
company and so like the reason why I
worked with guys cuz they did all this
for us right and what things were not
going well they still stepped up and you
know did the right thing and and that's
why they love us today but I think it
starts with having good product right
like if your products not good no matter
what you do for the customer is probably
not going to take you because then he's
putting his job at risk wrap it up there
all right let's thank the panel this is
great
thank you everybody
[Applause]